s'agissant de nos productions celle-ci
ont commencé début septembre 2021
et j'attire votre attention quand sa
qualité de responsable éditoriale
Monsieur Mohamed cifaoui a rappelé à
maintes reprises que ce qui était
attendu de nous ce n'était pas la
quantité mais la qualité
le bilan de ce qui a été fait bon
malheureusement je je dis quand même
cette toute petite phrase a été par la
presse malheureusement très partiel à
charge en relayant encore une fois des
contre-vérités
donc je prends un exemple
alors certes nous n'avons pas réalisé
beaucoup de vidéos et je vais vous en
expliquer les raisons plus loin mais
peut-être aussi que les vidéos que nous
avons réalisées n'ont pas suscité
l'adhésion souhaitée
mais il est évident que nos vidéos ont
été vues les mesures d'impact que nous
avons réalisé nous montre que toutes nos
productions ont touché des centaines de
milliers de personnes ça ça n'a pas été
dit
entre septembre et novembre 2021 en
prenant les statistiques sur Twitter sur
ce premier trimestre de production nos
tweets ont été vus par près de 2
millions d'internautes
entre décembre 2021 et février 2022 nous
tweets ont été vus par un million 100
personnes
un million cent mille
et puis il y a aussi quelque chose à
dire sur un seul trade du 12 mars 2022
sur la partie du deuxième trimestre 2022
sur un seul trade notre compte a été vu
par un million 900 000 personnes sur le
sanguinaire Mohamed Merah
donc voilà cela dit la qualité du
travail qui a été fourni
mais encore mieux et je sais que je
m'exprime devant l'opinion publique je
prends un témoin tous les spécialistes
du numérique que vous pourriez
solliciter d'ailleurs pour pour vraiment
établir un bilan il vous diront que le
plus important pour mesurer l'impact
d'un compte ce n'est pas le nombre de
followers
mais ce qui appelait le taux
d'impression autrement dit l'audience
réelle que qui est la vôtre
si vous voulez nous n'avons pas voulu
avec ce projet faire un feu de paille
shot paille étant
pouvant passer par la publicité
sponsorisée pour faire un maximum
d'affichage et avoir un chiffre
d'affichage mais créer une réelle
diffusion organique de nos productions
donc bien plus qualitative
donc sachez également que ces mesures
d'impact nous sommes en train de les
faire authentifier par constat
d'huissier dans la perspective de
l'enquête judiciaire et je tiens à votre
disposition